in die Hotelkette twenty five hours
beklagt im Gegensatz zu einigen
Konkurrenten keinen Fachkräftemangel
hier haben Sie bereits vor einem Jahr
auf die angespannte Lager am
Arbeitsmarkt reagiert und die vier tage-
man merkt schon dass diese vier Tage
Woche wirklich ein Bundes ist und wir
viele Bewerberinnen haben die sich auch
vor allem bewerben wegen der vier Tage
Woche weil sie das halt auch begrüßen
weil das auch einfach ja auch ein
schönes benefit ist vier Tage Woche
heißt hier Reduktion von 40 auf 36
Stunden also 9 Stunden am Tag Ergebnis
weniger Krankheitsfälle höhere
Motivation
die längere Zeit sich einfach komplett
einmal durchzuatmen wieder zu sich zu
kommen und dann auch wieder rezitive zu
sein für externe Faktoren und Menschen
81% der deutschen Arbeitnehmer wollen
die vier Tage Woche 73% davon bei vollem
Lohnausgleich weitere 8% würden auch
lohnabschläge hinnehmen dem folgte IG
Metall und zieht mit der Forderung vier
Tage Woche bei vollem Lohnausgleich in
die nächste Tarifrunde und sieht die
Chance damit die Arbeit auch gerechter
verteilen zu können Stichwort
teilzeitfalle wir sehen dass wir in
Deutschland die höchste freizeitquote
haben fast in Europa 11 Millionen
Beschäftigte wenn du nur ein kleiner
Teil wieder in Vollzeit damit kommen
könnte hätten wir für den
Fachkräftebedarf der Zukunft vieles
getan Arbeitgeber und Union laufen Sturm
die vier Tage-Woche würde die eh schon
hohen Arbeitskosten drastisch erhöhen
wenn die vier Tage Woche benutzt wird um
zu sagen wir können Wohlstand
Transformation und klimastabilität
erreichen mit weniger arbeiten dann ist
es eine Milchmädchenrechnung und die
sollten wir nicht weiter verfolgen schon
heute können fast zwei Millionen Stellen
in Deutschland nicht besetzt werden der
Mangel an Arbeits- und Fachkräften ist
die Wachstumsbremse Nummer eins und
führt dazu dass Deutschland im
internationalen Wettbewerb nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig ist doch was einige
noch übersehen ist dass eine neue
Generation in den Arbeitsmarkt wächst
für die Generation Z ist das Leben
wichtiger als die Arbeit work-life
balance nennen sie es
82 Prozent wollen die vier Tage Woche
74% flexible Arbeitszeiten 66 Prozent
Homeoffice doch aus den
Regierungsparteien kommt wenig bis keine
Unterstützung selbst der Arbeitsminister
aus der Arbeiterpartei hält sich
weitgehend zurück nur die Ko-Vorsitzende
der SPD zieht mit den Forderungen der
Generationszeit mit das heißt doch nur
das Arbeitgebern das Institutionen eben
sich auch darauf einstellen müssen
diesen wegen dieser geringeren großen
Generationen Ebenen Angebot zu machen
ein Angebot das auch verstehen
Flexibilität Bezahlung Sicherheit bietet
wenig Verständnis für die
Arbeitseinstellung der Generationszeit
hatte gegen Kirchentags Präsident Thomas
de Maiziere mich ärgert dass sie viel zu
viel an sich denken und wenig an die
Gesellschaft am 7 Tag sollst du ruhen
heißt es in der Bibel das bedeutet ein
Verhältnis von sechs zu eins und nicht
das Freizeit überwiegt in Wedel in
Schleswig-Holstein denkt man anders
Wedel braucht Nachwuchs und bietet als
erste Kommune die vier Tage Woche an
uns fehlen plötzlich ganz viele
erfahrene Fachkräfte jetzt heute und in
Zukunft das zweite ist natürlich auch es
hat sich die Denkweise bei jüngeren
Menschen auch geändert also ich denke
mal wenn man so will Karriere und Erfolg
ist mit sich in Zukunft nicht nur ein
Status und Geld sondern es hat was mit
der Sinnfrage auch zu tun in Deutschland
findet gerade eine Machtverschiebung
statt früher konnte sich der Arbeitgeber
den Arbeitnehmer aussuchen heute ist es
umgekehrt das macht trotz aller
Widerstände die vier Tage Woche als
Zukunftsmodell wahrscheinlicher